how do you fix a brain that's not
working properly
well until now the only real option has
been to open up the skull implant
electrical or optical fibers or even
remove parts of the brain if you do
something like surgery or ablation even
with ultrasound
that's an irreversible one-time
procedure but this scientist has a
different idea yeah sure yeah I'm
Mikhail Shapiro where should I look you
can look at me yeah I'm Mikhail Shapiro
I'm a professor of chemical engineering
at Caltech everything that we try to do
is to make it
non-invasive meaning that we don't want
to have any kind of surgery to open up
the skull and implant an electrode or we
don't want to have to open up the skull
to shine light onto the neurons we want
to do it using sound wave which is one
of the few forms of energy that can be
focused deep inside of the tissue and
can actually permeate through things
like the skull even the human skull this
is a curved transducer so you can see
there is a slight curvature in it that
will cause the sound waves to get
concentrated a few centimeters in front
of the face of this transducers for now
the research is being conducted on mice
and the idea is to be able to turn on
and off specific brain regions at will
without invasive surgery so the trick
that we employ here is that we take
something that's traditionally been a
really big problem in neuroscience drugs
and we turn it into an advantage so the
problem is that the brain has what's
called the blood-brain barrier which
lines the blood vessels of the brain and
prevents molecules in moving from the
bloodstream into the brain but in there
procedure they open the blood-brain
barrier in carefully targeted regions of
the brain so to do this we introduce
little bubbles into the blood stream air
bubbles bubbles of air but they are safe
bubbles so this is an fda-approved
clinically used like contrast agent
they're microns in scale okay tiny air
bubbles so tiny little air bubbles that
we introduce into the into the
bloodstream and so they're circulating
everywhere and then wherever we apply
the ultrasound the sound waves cause the
bubbles
to expand and contract in size and as
they're doing that they push against the
blood vessel walls and kind of massage
them open so they get that blood-brain
barrier that's normally caused by really
tight junctions between cells to open
just the crack so that now molecules can
get out into the brain and by using the
ultrasound you can target just specific
areas of the brain where you want to
open the blood-brain barrier and leave
the rest of the brain alone exactly once
the blood-brain barrier is open the
scientists inject especially made virus
that would normally not be able to pass
into the brain these viral vectors which
are viruses that we have hijacked so
that instead of them introducing their
DNA to the cells they're going to
introduce the DNA that we want and what
this gene produces are these receptors
that will go on to the neuron these
receptors have been modified so they no
longer respond to neurotransmitters that
are natively present inside the brain
and will instead respond to a drug that
we can inject that will activate just
those receptors and not act on anything
else I'll tell you when we get to a part
where your cameras going to get sucked
into the magnet before it happens thank
you I appreciate that so this big
machine here is what generates the sound
waves that we use this little device
will get installed on here and then
we're gonna have a mouse underneath and
then this entire thing is going to go
into the MRI scanner is this a special
ultrasound for mice both the MRI is
special for mice because as you can see
from the bore that's in the middle yeah
it was gonna fit in there yeah we'd have
to be a really small human and then our
ultrasound system also is designed for
these kind of small animals and that's
squeaking sound that I'm hearing that's
not actually mice in there
that's the MRI yeah how strong is the
magnetic field in there inside the
scanner is 7-tesla whoa yes so it's
going to give us an image of the anatomy
of the brain and allow us to target the
focus of this ultrasound transducer to
precisely the part of the brain where we
want to open the blood-brain barrier
there will be four bright spots that
will appear on the brain just about here
so this is the opening of the barrier
between the blood and the brain that
allows a diffusion of what is
essentially a magnetic resonance imaging
dye that shows up during the MRI imaging
this is the hippocampus
picabo's is a fairly large structure
that's important in the formation of
memory and this is the one that we
targeted in our recent study - much like
the memory of mice we targeted the
hippocampus which is this part of the
brain that's necessary for the formation
of certain kinds of memories and using
our technique we can address just the
neurons within the hippocampus and when
we give a drug those neurons get shut
down and then we can do behavioral
experiments where we did a memory task
where we put the mice into a particular
environment and check to the next day by
bringing the mice back into that same
environment whether or not they could
remember it and for the mice that were
treated with the ultrasounds with the
receptors through the viral vectors and
given the drug that activates these
receptors that shut down the hippocampus
those mice were not able to remember so
we could tell that we were successfully
able to inhibit or prevent memory
formation because the effect depends on
when you give this drug and how much of
the drug you give you can have
reversible turning on or off of the
effect that you're trying to produce so
for example shutting down the part of
the brain that's causing a seizure so
another part of the brain that we're
pretty interested in is called the
ventral tegmental area which is a part
of the brain that uses the
neurotransmitter dopamine and is
involved in things like motivation and
addiction and initiation and control of
movement and if we can gain control over
the neurons in that area it might
someday be used
four treatments for some of these
motivational or affective disorders like
addiction and our depression could you
use this to control people's brains like
by playing ultrasound you know some area
no there is not a chance at least using
our technology that you could be walking
around and we could be controlling your
brain remotely if that's what you're not
yet anyway that is not our goal
hey this video was supported by viewers
like you on patreon and by Skillshare
Skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of classes in a
wide range of subjects everything from
video production and animation to
business marketing entrepreneurship and
more now the idea is they get actual
experts working in their fields to teach
these classes for example they have a
class on animation bikers cassette and I
personally found that class really
informative and helpful I mean who
wouldn't want to animate like kurz
cassette in fact in making the
animations for this video I worked
closely with a professional editor and
animator and I was better able to do
that thanks to taking this class now if
you want to check it out the first 500
people to sign up via the link below get
two months free and besides that it's
less than ten dollars a month so
definitely a worthwhile investment if
you want to upskill in any of the areas
they offer that Premium Membership gives
you unlimited access to any and all
classes on the platform and I should
probably point out that this makes a
great gift idea to or just as a way to
start the new year with some new skills
and knowledge so I really want to thank
Skillshare for supporting veritasium and
I want to thank you for watching